okay before you go I want to play the
uncancel game with you one time okay
okay
you're put in charge of Tory Lanez and
his PR
two scenarios before he landed what
Tori's a good friend of mine yeah so I
like Tori I know um he's a good guy I
mean listen he [__] up obviously so
yeah
he's been a good guy to me let's just
say that but
let's say the day after all this happens
he's in jail you're his PR guy
how do you handle this what do you tell
him to do
stay off the phone
but I'm saying like Okay I mean when you
realize all this is going to come out
it's getting ugly do you tell them to
just come out and admit it dude no I
mean I think you know whatever a person
goes through legally is their private is
their business but I feel like once you
get on there once you make a song and
then you write horse or something
referencing a horse when you know Megan
the stallion you put out the album the
day that the uh what was the verdict of
the young lady who got killed uh by the
cops uh um
Brown Taylor Brianna Taylor yeah the
same that yeah okay when you pop out
when you have debate when you have uh
when you pull up on the baby set right
after Megan got off stage you're rolling
loud when you yeah when you do all of
that I mean like you're not I'll quit
you're not quit like you can't really
when you politic the media to try to
create a narrative that you're innocent
when you know that the Trials come in
and at some point the stakes are so high
your freedom in this country is at stake
your career is at stake like women your
audience women are sick like you're
going at some point you're making all
these decisions because people believe
the court of public opinion is more
important than anything so you're trying
to Gaslight people but what he failed to
realize is that ultimately women who've
been victimized by men for years are
going to switch whenever the
conversation changes and the
conversation changes and so yeah I would
have just advised them to
stay focused on his music stay focused
on rehabilitating that relationship stay
focused on all things positive you can
change The Narrative of positive content
but he wanted to be the bad boy of r b
and or whatever he doesn't right careers